we were on a train early on into the
operation there was a guy sitting on the
train opposite with his wife and his two
kids and he had a crystal palace lapel
badge
just a little badge on his jacket
the guy saw it he lent the cross and he
punched the bloke squarely in the face
and then hit him three more times
in front of his wife and his two kids he
were two little girls he must have been
aged four and six
[Music]
my dad was a police officer i grew up in
south london
and
i got to about 15
and my friends we were all going one way
or the other
and uh i just felt one side of the fence
they fell the other side so i joined the
police cadets when i was 16 so uh
it um
it sort of worked on from there really
but it wasn't something that i was
actively choosing to do
at that age just sort of fell into a
little bit really
so how from there how did you get into
undercover work
um so i left the police cadets i joined
the
regular force when i was 18 and a half i
got mentored by her
by a sergeant who used to be in plain
clothes he saw something in me
and i started to work in plain clothes
from
an early
uh really quite early within sort of
three months
uh and then within 18 months i was on a
crime squad i got special dispensation
because i was still in probation
i just took to it quite
naturally i
was um
i suppose one of a better word chosen to
uh to work in an um in an undercover
environment
i was i was 21
so i think it was probably the youngest
officer that had done that certainly at
that time
what does it take to be a good
undercover officer
you have to be um you have to be really
good at lying
and to convince people that you're
something that you're not
you have to have a massive ego
in order to put yourself in an
environment where you think you can
survive
um
pretty confident
um
quite bright in a way in that you can
think on your feet quite quickly
uh in order to get yourself in or out of
situations
there isn't a one there isn't one
specific you don't sort of get it's not
that sort of career or that sort of that
job or that profession that you do that
you could um you know you get to a
certain age and they go oh you'd be
quite good at doing maybe be good at
working undercover it's just not an
exact science
it just is something that either you can
do or you can't
so how do you choose your undercover how
do you choose what what specifically
you're going to be doing
you don't
you
that gets chosen for you really the job
that i was given was to infiltrate
mealwood football hooligans the police's
aim was to to try and rid
that hooligan culture and to get
in with
the people that were organizing and
creating the issues and the problems and
the fights
and that would involve about the
arranging where they were fighting the
actual fights that they carried out the
assaults and everything else that that
that goes along with that
so yeah there are there are certain
clubs that attract
hooligan element
so millwall leeds west ham chelsea um
were clubs that that had had had a
bigger
attraction to football hooligans and
millwall was just
was was one of the top clubs and it was
a reputation that they deserved for one
of a better word is they were
a
force to be reckoned with
so i did my research
and i did everything i could to know
about the team
before and the current team and previous
teams to try and get as much information
because you've got to remember i was
suddenly appearing from nowhere
they're quite a tight-knit
group of people
and suddenly this this new face or these
two new faces appear is you need to try
and put yourself in the best position
that you can in order to
to progress yourself further up
up up
the ranks as it may be in relation to
football so can you
talk me through your
legend yeah my legend um
we weren't given a great deal of help
when we first started
and my legend when i initially started
was
a
business card
on which that business card was that i
was a
i was gym-fulled
i worked for spectrum decorating and i
um
had an address which was a um which was
an accommodation address
in croydon
that was it
that was my legend
um i made out that i was from wandsworth
and that i was a painter and decorator
so going in and saying i'm jim you've
never met me before
i'm a lifelong mealworld supporter
although i've never been here and they
asked me who i am i go don't worry
here's my business card
that was about as good as it got
and we learned very very very quickly
that we needed a little bit more so we
started to go into
a mealworld pub
and we used to go in at lunch times
and then because no one went in there
and then whilst we went in at lunchtime
we'd then befriend the bar staff
and we went in for three months solid
pretty much every lunch everywhere every
lunch time so we became regular fixtures
when we then turned up at football in
the september
um you would walk in and the pub would
go quiet and everyone would look at
everybody as they came in because it was
that sort of pub we walked in everyone
looked at us and obviously the bar mates
who were behind the bar recognized us
and called us out and as a result of
that
everyone accepted us because obviously
the bar staff would accept us
so on that basis they ask us questions
we gradually just we went to went to the
matches we went away we started to
um
spend quite a lot of money buy lots of
drinks
make sure that we were always there
and we got a bit lucky
we went on our we went on a
uh on a special on a football special to
leeds
we went on the train and met up with
three guys
who we got on with and as a result of
that it fools the relationship and it
just went on from there what were the
worst things you've seen uh the most
frightening one for me was arsenal in
the fourth round of the fa cup
so we went
and
we were at that stage we were quite well
in with some with with some of the
hooligans and we ended up me and the
sergeant in the north bank which was the
away end of arsenal
um
so
yeah we
we went in
we were in the middle of so you can
imagine it we were standing there there
was 15 of us
we were surrounded by 8 000 arsenal
and i'm standing there thinking this is
not good and one of the guys picked up
on it they were a lot older than me and
said look don't worry everything's going
to be fine opened his jacket and showed
me he had a six inch stiletto knife
so i'm now thinking this can this is
going to get this can be really
problematic here
and i'm standing there singing along
thinking no one likes us but actually
within me i'm thinking i'm gonna die
and um
it's
very very quickly they realized who we
were
so the crowd moved out
and then there was there's because there
always is the initial start the first
guy came forward
the art one of the arsenal guys came
running towards us coming towards me
because i was the youngest and probably
the smallest
and one of the other guys just stepped
out and
hit him straight on the nose and the guy
went completely
did a complete 360 and came down and
just crashed onto the concrete terraces
and it was
you can imagine there's
quite a lot going on at this stage it
went completely quiet and everyone
including us and all of the arsenal
supporters just went
and then these two little guys just
appeared from nowhere
and the crowd sort of opened up and they
picked this grabbed this guy by the legs
and pulled him back in it was a bit like
benner he just like sort of disappeared
back in and the crowd closed
and then it all kicked off
and one thing you learn very very
quickly in that environment is that you
don't go down
you stand up because the minute you go
down you're in all sorts of trouble
and so i was just kicking and punching
and ended up out on the pitch
and
got arrested
but the guy made a bit of a mistake is
instead of leading me to
the tunnel where they take you down this
way
he let me read me this way
which took me towards ten thousand
million
and as we were leaving i could tell by
the way he was holding me that he was
starting to get quite nervous
and he'd started and he now couldn't
stop so we start to walk towards the 10
000 mil wall
and i saw my chance and he wasn't
holding on to me time and as we got
close to the crowd i managed to break
free
we threw a couple of coppers and then
dived in the crowd and from then on it
was i um i was well and truly accepted
how scared were you
i was absolutely [ __ ] myself
yeah
feel like that and but the adrenaline is
absolutely huge
and so
you are
it's for you know that you're in that
position is you've got
you're not gonna be able to run away in
that scenario you just have to go with
what you've got
so yeah it was absolutely petrified
but at the same time
it's unbelievably exhilarating and
you're trying to get yourself in the
position where to
to safety
and when you do and you survive it's
quite euphoric
how does it actually feel to
to effectively leave your life
pretending you're someone else
um you just you get used to it i just
it was a job
and i know people find that really they
just go yeah but it was a job and people
some people love their jobs and some
people hate their jobs and i really love
that job
but but it was a job
but i wanted to be the best
at that that i that i could be
and in order to do that there were
occasions when i had to behave like a
hooligan
but that was my job
was to be
a hooligan and so on that basis
is i had to
display certain characteristics in order
to convince people that that's what i
was
because if i didn't
then i wouldn't get the evidence that i
needed
and i wouldn't be any good at what i did
did you ever get emotionally connected
to anyone yeah of course
so lots of them they're really some of
them are really nice guys
they just like to have a fight at
football
but there are an element that just
really aren't very nice at all
and the best place for them is
is not to be on the terraces
i'm just trying to imagine them kind of
the mental strain of
it's horrendous i'm going through things
like that all the time
so the worst the worst the
the worst situation on the operation was
we were on a train early on into the
operation we were traveling to london
with a target that we just got to know
there was a guy sitting on the train
opposite with his wife and his two kids
and he had a crystal palace lapel badge
just a little badge on his jacket
the guy saw it
he lent the cross and he punched the
bloke squarely in the face
and then hit him three more times
in front of his wife and his two kids he
were two little girls he must have been
aged four and six
so for me
i stood up on the seats and started
singing no one likes us
in order to detract to try and detract
attention and he stopped
and it worked because he stopped
the look from the two little girls who
were now crying
and the wife
and him but particularly from the two
girls who were looking at me standing up
singing no one likes us i'll never
forget
because everything
within me and the sergeant
just wanted to arrest him
but i couldn't
so we had to
endure that rest of that train train
journey
with this guy
bleeding from the nose
being confronted being comforted by his
wife and these two kids crying
until we got off at london bridge
hoping that he would report it
and at a later date the guy could be
arrested and he could be held
accountable for his actions but he never
reported it
so that was
for me
the worst experience during that whole
time did you ever feel guilty about any
of that
it's not all of us we all question about
what we do
as we get older about whether or not
that was a good thing or a bad thing
but it was my job
you can't justify it by saying that all
the time
but it was that was what i was there to
do and i chose to take that job and so
for me was the important thing was to
try and do it
as convincingly as i can and the more
convincing i was the safer i was going
to be
have you ever been close to being
exposed
we had um an experience where we had an
incident where the sergeant who i'd been
working with had told the guys that we
were working
uh on a job in catford
which we were but we weren't there that
week
and they'd gone down to see us
and we weren't there and the guys didn't
know when they started asking
where's jim and they just don't know who
you're talking about because they were
doing the roof
we turned up
um on the saturday and got confronted
about the fact that who are you we came
down to your job and i'm going watch
other than what you're talking about
because
the sudden hadn't made me aware of the
fact that they'd had this conversation
and we ended up in a situation where
we got
confronted and called out
and again that was another situation
where you stand there and think
right
what do i do here is we either run away
or we front it up
and
i fronted it out
and
we got away with it
did you felt like you were in danger
at that point
yeah to put it in perspective
you're in danger all the time
because you were in a scenario where you
just don't know what is going to happen
next
so it's but there are different levels
of danger
so you put yourself every time you put
yourself or go into a pub or go into go
go to a match or do anything
you are leaving yourself you're exposing
yourself to
to to danger
it's just about how you deal with that
and how in you how you best
make sure that you can control it as
best that you can
so they're just just levels but all of
the time it's dangerous
it's just
about
how you deal with that and
what level of danger is dangerous enough
for you to go i'm out of here now
when you walk undercover could you
actually tell your friends or family or
anyone what are you doing the person i
was living with at the time knew
she knew but it had has an impact
it is a um you know you come home and
start
with all jobs that we all do is you come
home and try and switch off
and but with that it's quite difficult
you tend to try and tell the least
amount of people as possible but
people will pick up on it is the fact
that i went from
12 stone pretty fit with short hair
to
15 and a half 16 stone
long hair earrings
completely physically different
within within two years
so people will and you're meant to be a
serving police officer and people know
that
they would look at you and think he's
certainly not walking the beat
not looking like that
so how long
overall did you spend on the cover at
millwall two and a half years
and what was the outcome of your
operation the operation was concluded on
a phone call
finished
no one was arrested
nobody was brought to justice nobody was
there was no trial he just it was just
concluded overnight
on a phone call
why
there'd been some really bad publicity
around
um
operations that the similar operations
at west ham and chelsea and both of the
trials had collapsed and they collapsed
due to
police officers
making up evidence and lying
um and the chelsea trial was
didn't even get to a decision where it
was a verdict it was it was it was
halted
and it was because it was proven very
very quickly
that what was happening is that the
officers were
were fabricating evidence and making it
up
and
the reason for that is
is
again it's not an ego thing it's just
you know it's just an honest assumption
is
they weren't very good and because they
weren't very good they didn't manage to
get the evidence that they needed so in
order to try and convince people that
they were better than they were they
made it up
and they got caught out
and as a result of that
the police false as it was then the
police service as it is now decided that
that's surely maybe that's what everyone
else was doing so in order to
not have the
adverse publicity the trials that all of
the operations were shut down overnight
and
ours was probably the highest profile
one that just stopped
how did it feel for it to end in one day
i was angry
just because
i'd spent too much two and a half years
and it was my job and i'd spent two and
a half years of doing this great job and
getting this evidence and there was
sufficient evidence for a number of
people to have been arrested and charged
and then the way that we were dealt with
afterwards was
appalling really
um considering what we'd done
we were given two weeks off and then put
back in uniform and for me told to go
back to auburn and drive a panda car
so
i left
how old were you when you left the
police force 23.
i'd experienced an awful lot and seen
um a different side of police officers
than i had before
because obviously as a
working in an undercover environment
they were
fully unaware who i was they just
thought i was just another
millwall football hooligan traveling
around the country and
i didn't see a particularly good or nice
side of certainly people that police
football back then
and um i didn't really want to be
associated with
with people like that particularly in
that environment because there's really
really good police officers
but there are an awful lot that aren't
very good
and um
so i was
quite relieved really to be to be out of
that
so yeah i just looked at it as a new
chapter
closed the book and then then moved on
so did undercover work change your view
of football
no it changed my view of police
it didn't change my view of football
no i think it was um
i enjoyed my time it was great it was
like it was it was the majority of the
time it was really good fun
you know i got to
were flying at that time and got into
the what is the now the premier ship now
got into the old first division
so we were going to amazing grounds with
amazing support
and um
and i got to do that for two and a half
years so there were some massive
positives as a result of that
and they were an amazing team
but yeah the biggest change for me was
was my
attitudes towards
towards the police
so how did that change
i particularly liked them very much if
i'm being honest i'm in particular you
know again it's um we are you know we're
in an innocent in a in a situation where
you know we're being corralled and the
way the police was the way that football
was police back then was completely
different to how it is now and it was no
surprise that we ended up with
the tragedies that we did because of the
way that they that they policed and the
way that they forced people into into
and tried to contain them
and again i've not seen that because it
was
i'm not saying that all police officers
it's just that in that at that time and
in that environment is
they just
they weren't particularly good at what
they did
what would you say was the best thing
about undercover work
on a personal level
convincing people that you're something
that you're not
unbelievably satisfying
to for people to
you know again which is the acting thing
is
to to do a good job and in order to do
that for people to
believe in
your character
and so that's probably the most
for me was the most satisfying
but again probably the most disturbing
was the fact
that you managed to convince somebody
that all these people that you're not
which isn't
a great thing to do either so it's a bit
double edged really
when i started that operation i was i
was a kid
i was a
spotty 21 year old
when i finished it i was a much heavier
much longer-haired
man
[Music]
and as they were walking around me
one of them would
punch me headbutt me as this was going
on the guy was looking down at me asking
me questions and i became convinced
that i wasn't going to leave there in
one piece